en este vídeo vamos a trabajar ahora con
la hipérbola exactamente lo mismo que
hicimos con el círculo vamos a encontrar
restricciones en donde intersecte la
línea tangente en términos de m pero en
este caso utilizando a la hipérbole y
después quizás podamos igualar los entre
sí y resolverlos para m
entonces recordemos que la ecuación de
la hipérbola es bueno en aquellos noción
en este caso de ejemplo es x cuadrada
sobre 9 - y cuadradas sobre 4 igual a 1
y entonces vamos a escribirla por acá la
ecuación es x cuadrada sobre 9 menos de
cuadrada sobre 4 y todo esto igual a 1
pero bueno deje libre el espacio de la
ye cuadrada pero primero la voy a
escribir bien para que se entienda solo
que hay que recordar que la que ya
tenemos ya la habíamos manejado
anteriormente y es la ecuación que
teníamos por acá arriba donde ya
habíamos resuelto también su cuadrado
que se me cuadrada por equis cuadrada
más toda esta esta parte que está aquí
entonces la podríamos sustituir sin
ningún problema porque ese es el punto
del ejercicio encontrar una misma línea
que intersecta tanto a la hipérbola como
el círculo entonces no hay problema y
bueno ahora
a multiplicar ambas partes de la
ecuación por 36 dado que es un múltiplo
común de 9 y 4 y bueno no nos afectaría
al multiplicar la por ambos lados y es
para quitar las fracciones así que esto
36 entre 9 nos queda 4x cuadrada menos
30 y 64 9% cuadrada en donde en este
caso vamos a escribir ya lo que tenemos
de ye cuadrada del vídeo anterior
entonces aquí es m cuadrada por x
cuadrada más dos veces m por ver por x
más b cuadrada y todo esto todo esto va
a ser igual va a ser igual a 36 pues
recuerda que multiplicamos ambas partes
de la ecuación por 36 y aquí sólo
tenemos 1 entonces esos 36 y ahora ahora
dando lo mismo como con nosotros ya
sabíamos cómo sabíamos m la m y la ye
como lo trabajamos en el vídeo anterior
la m y la b deben ser tales que la línea
tenga una pendiente positiva y tal que
solo intersecte con la hipérbola en un
solo punto y no se entregue entonces una
sola solución y aquí tenemos otra vez
una ecuación cuadrática que puede
a carla en términos de equis pero el
primero simplificamos todo y
preocupémonos por eso entonces al
resolver esto va a ser 4x cuadrada menos
9 m cuadra de x cuadrada multiplicar
menos 18 m por b por x menos 9 por b
cuadrada y ahora voy a pasar a esto solo
es al multiplicar voy a pasar el 36
dentro del lado de la ecuación para que
esto no se quede igual a 0 y entonces
aquí tenemos una ecuación cuadrática en
términos de x y ahora vamos a tratar de
ordenar o combinar los diferentes
términos con respecto a sus grados
entonces estos de por aquí van a ser los
términos sólo los que tienen a la x
cuadrada entonces nos va a quedar 4
menos 9 por m cuadrada y todo a su vez x
x cuadrada luego el término de acá es el
único que tiene x por lo que nos queda
exactamente igual menos 18 por m por b
por x y finalmente las constantes las
que no tienen ningún término de x y
esperamos escribir menos menos 9
por vez cuadrada o no mejor lo voy a
simplificar por de tal forma de que me
sirva más a mí el factorizar la pero
pero no yo creo que sí mejor lo hago más
adelante lo que quiera factorizar la los
términos de 9 y 36 pero creo que sólo va
a ser mejor más adelante entonces todo
esto va a ser igual a 0 y recuerda que
como es una forma de cuadrática si
nosotros la queremos resolver respecto a
x nosotros tenemos la fórmula general de
segundo grado que habíamos puesto por
acá y que este discriminante que tenía
aquí adentro tenía que ser igual a cero
como lo hicimos en el vídeo pasado para
que digamos que este b cuadrada menos 4
hace es igual a 0 para que digamos que
sí tenemos una tangente y ahora ahora
distinguiendo este término de aquí base
debe cuadrada y una vez más no te vas a
confundir que es la abe cuadrada porque
este término tiene a b no tienen nada
que ver son independientes entonces éste
va a ser be cuadrada y sería 18 al
cuadrado por elmer cuadrado por b al
cuadrado y como teníamos el signo
negativo al cuadrado se vuelve positivo
menos cuatro veces la a donde
es el 4 menos nueve por m cuadrada por c
donde se nos representa las constantes
que tenemos por aquí la voy a escribir
de tal forma que sean menos 9 estoy
factores ando en 9 por el menos nueve
por be cuadrada entonces aquí adentro en
nuestros coches decir al ave cuadrada
más 4 por 9 es menos 36 entonces ésta
está todo bien y debes de tener mucho
cuidado con este tipo de factorización
es para no cometer errores entonces aquí
tenemos el menos 9 y éste menos 4 se va
a volver un 36 se va se vuelve un 36
positivo y después sólo vamos a
simplificar las cosas lo que vamos a
hacer es una especie como de fantasía
matemática pues tenemos tenemos que este
18 al cuadrado y recordemos recordemos
que esto es la misma cosa o bueno en sí
creo que todavía no me conviene hacer el
siguiente paso pero primero voy a
empezar con algo que sea visible no
entonces esto este 18 al cuadrado es lo
mismo exactamente lo mismo que si
ponemos 2 por 9 2 por 9 por 2 por 9 al
resolverlo te tiene que dar el mismo
y entonces a su vez esto es igual a 4
por 9 por 9 y bueno después más adelante
vamos a poder dividir aquí algunos
términos para que se nos cancelen varias
cosas pero recuerda que toda esta
ecuación nos interesa que sea igual a
cero entonces eso nos ayuda a poder
dividir ya que sea igual a cero ambas
partes de la ecuación poderla dividir
entre 36 o bien que es la misma cosa que
dividir entre 4 por 9 entonces este
término de aquí este término de aquí a
dividir entre 4 por 9 se nos van a
cancelar y entonces nos lleva a tener
solamente 9 por m cuadrada por b
cuadrada y recordemos que todo lo
estamos dividiendo entre 36
entonces nos va a ir este menos 4 x
menos 9 y nos quedan simplemente más
estas cosas y entonces hay que resolver
este producto de estos dos términos lo
que nos va a dar el 4 x b cuadrada nos
va a dar más 4 b cuadrada pero déjame lo
pongo mejor otro color para que se
distinga el otro término entonces sería
más 4 b cuadrada luego 4 x 4
+ 16 luego tenemos menos 9 me cuadrada
por b cuadrada nos quedan menos 9 m
cuadrada por b cuadrada y luego menos 9
cuadrada por el más 4 lo que eso nos da
menos 36 y todo esto menos 36 m cuadrada
y todo esto igual a 0 y ahora si
observas por suerte estos dos términos
se nos cancelan y ahora ahora todo esto
si puedes ver nos queda divisible entre
4 entonces no nos afecta en nada
entonces esto nos va a quedar 4 b
cuadrada entre 4 no es clave cuadrada
que ese es el primer término menos menos
36 entre 4 nos va a quedar 9 en 9m
cuadrada y finalmente es este término de
puerta y finalmente 16 entre 4 nos
quedan más 4 y todo esto será entre 4
nos va a quedar igual a 0 y una vez más
podemos usar la fórmula general para
resolver esto pero bueno de hecho aquí
no es necesario necesario utilizar la
fórmula nosotros lo podemos resolver
para ver pues esto es podemos separar
esto
como en dos partes y entonces vamos a
tener que ver cuadrada es igual a la
raíz de 9 m cuadrada menos 4 no haber
esperar ya me equivoqué no b cuadrada no
va a ser igual a esto es que están aquí
arreglando unas cosas y me está
distrayendo creo que no me está dejando
trabajado concentrar muy bien pero vamos
a hacerlo bien y olvidemos este paso que
estuvo fatal entonces será be cuadrada
igual a 9 m cuadrada menos 4 es como
está despejando y entonces ahora sí
ahora sí ve cuadrada es igual a esto
entonces al despejar no nos va a quedar
b igual a la raíz de 9 me cuadrada menos
4 y si observamos esto luce bastante
bastante bien pues ahora hay que ver la
situación no dejemos la situación donde
ve tiene que tender hacia la hipérbola
convirtiéndose en esto pues a lo largo
la tangente también lo fue del círculo
entonces esto lo vimos en el vídeo
anterior que era lo mismo que hacerlo
para ver así que ahora déjame pegarlo
por aquí ve tenemos que era igual a eso
en cuanto al círculo vamos a pegar la
vez del círculo por aquí
y entonces podemos establecer que son
iguales con una con otra y resolver lo
que tenemos ayudándonos para sacar la m
y obtener la pendiente de dicha línea
tangente seguir adelante y resolverlo
para ver lo cual en el siguiente vídeo